Tom Friedman is a best-selling
author and the foreign affairs columnist
for The New York Times a Minnesota
native tom has starred at the New York
Times for three decades as a foreign
correspondent bureau chief in the Middle
East as White House correspondent chief
White House correspondent and as
international economics correspondent
and since 1995 as a provocative globe
traveling columnist indeed before we
joined the Pulitzer Prize board in 2004
Tom had 13 Pulitzer Prizes 24
international reporting from Lebanon and
Israel and one for commentary few rival
that record his six best-selling books
have spanned major world problems his
first book in 1989 from Beirut to
Jerusalem drew on rich experiences in
the Middle East there was a winner of
the National Book Award for nonfiction
or recently you probably remember these
mind stretching books the world is flat
a brief history of the 21st century
which became a number one New York Times
bestseller followed by hot flat and
crowded why we need a green revolution
and how it can renew America and last
year he co-authored that used to be us
how Americans fell behind in the world
we invented and how we can come back
clearly tom is a deep thinker who
worries about America losing its groove
he is much pursued as a speaker and at
last count has received 14 honorary
degrees above all tom is a relentless
roving reporter forever in the field
engaging digging and analyzing his motto
is
if you don't go you don't know ladies
and gentlemen Tom Friedman
sig thank you very much it's a treat to
be here this afternoon normally I'd be
really nervous getting up in front of a
credible audience like this in an
amazing hall but i have to tell you last
Friday I was on Jeopardy that is really
scary haha prepared me for anything on
behalf of Greg and myself I want to
thank you all for being here this
afternoon at this happy occasion before
I share a few remarks so I want to say
that I am entering my ninth and final
year on the Pulitzer board and
throughout that time I and my colleagues
have benefited from the endless good
judgment good cheer an even temper of
the pulitzer administrator sig Gissler
the pulitzer trust and board
the pulitzer trust and board are hugely
in his debt anyone who has served on
this board during six ten year will tell
you that since the only thing standing
between you all and your Pulitzer Prizes
is my speech I promise I will not be
long I thought I would simply take a few
minutes to share with you what I have
learned from eight years of judging the
best journalism produced in this country
for starters the first thing I've
learned is how much good journalism
still gets produced in America despite
the shrinkage of new souls and news
budgets while we on the board get to see
the best of the best the three finalists
in every category chosen by different
juries more often than not I find myself
wanting to give prizes to all three it
is often excruciating ly hard to choose
our industry may not be so alive and
well but our craft certainly is as a
board member one not only gets to savor
all this good journalism but to learn
from its substance as well in that
regard I have noticed a worrying trend
of late in recent years but particularly
this year the finals included numerous
stories about state and local
governments as well as the federal
government being squeezed by budget cuts
and as a result either failing to do
their jobs or outsourcing them to
private contractors who motivated more
by profit than civic duty often
underperformed as well let me share with
you a sample what I mean from a few of
our finalists and winners this year the
Miami Herald offered a sweeping thorough
and meticulous investigation over a
year-long period that uncovered abuses
and lack of state oversight at Florida's
once acclaimed assisted living
facilities The Herald conducted hundreds
of interviews and examined thousands of
state inspections police reports and
court cases through careful
reconstruction of individual cases it
showed how some of Florida's most
vulnerable citizens suffered Grievous
injury or death
because of neglect and abuse and how the
state failed to shut down homes even
after repeated violations the New York
Times through exhaustive reporting
revealed rapes beatings and more than
1,200 unexplained deaths in state-run
facilities that ate a hundred and
thirty-five thousand developmentally
disabled citizens they also found that
New York taxpayers were paying far more
for care than citizens in any other
state with some organizations handing
top executives handsome salaries and
questionable benefits the Chicago
Tribune using old-fashioned
investigative techniques presented a
clear and convincing indictment of a
system that allowed criminals by the
dozens to escape the consequences of
their brutal acts by simply fleeing the
country reporters did what law
enforcement failed to do they track down
those violent fugitives often living
under their real names and interviewed
many of them along with families
victimized by their crimes the report
has also identified law enforcement
agencies which through neglect or
indifference apparently forgot that
crime without punishment was justice
denied the Seattle Times whose methadone
and politics of pain series provided a
compelling report on how a little-known
government agency moved Medicaid
patients from safer pain control
medication to the more dangerous but
cheaper methadone the main advertiser
Democrat which exhibited extraordinary
resourcefulness and tenacity in exposing
a stunning failure by local state and
federal housing authorities to protect
the most vulnerable members of their
small rural Maine community with only a
staff of three the papers robust
reporting in photography uncovered a
blatant disregard for health and safety
codes that prompted the state to launch
an official investigation literally
within four hours of publication of the
first story The Associated Press for
clearly and dispassionately exposing how
regulators have walked away from
traditional standards of safety even as
nuclear facilities reaching or
surpassing their life expectancy showed
troubling signs of leakage decay and
outright failure and finally the
California
and Center for Investigative Reporting
offered a shocking discovery of
deficiencies in the seismic safety of
California school buildings the entry
included an online edition where you
could click on your school and see the
fault line running under it it is a
truism that Americans today of all
political stripes want more government
than they are willing to pay for but I
must say serving on this board you can
really start seeing the effects we are
leaving as I wrote yesterday a period of
50 years went to be a president a
governor or mayor or a college president
was on balance to give things away to
people and we are entering a period
hopefully brief in which to be a
president a governor or mayor or a
college president will be on balance to
take things away from people how
intelligently we as a country do that I
believe is going to determine a lot
about the quality of life in our country
you can grow without pain but you better
you can grow without a plan but you
better not cut without a plan I suspect
that a lot of what our news
organizations will be covering in the
next decade is how we cut things how
intelligently we use our shrinking
resources and what impact or failure to
do so has on businesses schools jobs
families and our social fabric in other
words ladies and gentlemen of the press
we have a hugely important task waiting
for us down the road another thing i've
noticed these past eight years is at the
New York Times Wall Street Journal in
Washington Post sure went a lot of
pulitzer prizes for international
reporting and here i am going to make a
tradition they're going to win a lot
more because so many other news
organizations have dramatically cut back
their foreign coverage I was in Amman
Jordan two weeks ago and gave a talk at
the teacher's college in Amman where
columbia university also has a center at
the reception afterwards a man came up
to me warmly shook my hand and asked do
you
recognize me I did not he was Yusuf
nazzal the owner of the Commodore hotel
the famous press paying out for the
Beirut press corps for many years
culminating during the israeli invasion
of 1982 i was thinking about the
Commodore and seeing Yusuf in preparing
my remarks today because when I looked
around the Commodore lobby in the summer
of nineteen eighty-two I saw
correspondence from the Washington Post
and New York Times as well as the Wall
Street Journal Los Angeles Times
Baltimore Sun Chicago Tribune
Philadelphia Enquirer Miami Herald
Dallas Morning News Associated Press
news day United Press International
Reuters AFP CNN NBC CBS ABC Time
Newsweek and US news and world report
every major british french italian and
spanish paper was there along with
photographers from every agency some of
those news organizations don't even
exist anymore and some have so long ago
given up foreign reporting they don't
even remember they were in it the upside
of course is that a huge number of
websites and bloggers have emerged to
tell their stories and many of them are
locals who are telling their own story
to the world bravely intimately and with
the perceptiveness that only an insider
can offer I for one have benefited
enormously from these new voices like
now Lebanon in Beirut for instance but I
don't know how many Americans have the
patience or energy to ferret them out
and so I cannot help but feel a certain
melancholy and unease that at a time
when the world has never been more
interconnected and therefore never more
interdependent American news
organizations have fewer and fewer
resources to cover the globe we are
going to have to find more creative and
cost efficient ways to visit the world
on behalf of our readers before the
world visits us again as it did on 911
finally people often ask and especially
this year when the board did not award a
prize for fiction what our debates and
discussions are really like without
speaking about
specific entries let me try to lift the
shroud just a bit being on this board is
like being in the best book club in the
world and yes the debates at time do get
heated I will always save her the
opportunity I had to watch professor
professors henry louis gates of harvard
and david kennedy of stanford debating
the merits of a particular book of
history their back and forth was
pay-per-view quality at times it made
you want to lean back pop popcorn and
just enjoy the show I'm always amazed in
our discussions that one can be totally
allied with one person on the merits of
a particular book or piece of journalism
and then their staunchest opponents on
the next one and I'm equally amazed at
how I can come in feeling one thing
about a book or a series and be
persuaded by another board members
original argument and insights about
that work to vote another way it's a
strange mix you have to walk in that
boardroom with books both strong
convictions and an open mind because
there are a lot of people smarter than
you there on any given subject who
wouldn't pay attention to someone like
Junot Diaz it Pulitzer winner and
fiction and now on our board incisively
analyzing a novel as only another
fiction offered author can do while he
paces around our board table or lies
flat on his aching back on the floor
it's like a great fiction class who
cannot be touched when are always
soft-spoken fellow board member Joyce
Dealey reads aloud stanzas from her
favorite poet to sway the board to her
side before Daniel Ellen our board
member from the Princeton Institute for
Advanced Study deconstructs the same
poem with expert precision I still miss
Washington Post publisher Don grams
passionate and baroque way of
introducing any entry he liked or wanted
to demolish it was like watching a great
lawyer opening a case and I shall
certainly miss the two women from the
class before me who always sat next to
each other Kathleen Carroll executive
editor of The Associated Press and
Annemarie Lipinski curator of the Newman
foundation you only need to be on a
board
with the two of them for one year let
alone eight to say to yourself how could
there have been a time when women were
not top editors through it all though I
can tell you that I have never witnessed
an iota of favoritism or bias toward any
paper or author people truly take their
judging duties seriously to be executed
if I may use a motto close to home
without fear or favor yes at times has
happened this year with fiction there is
no winner but do not assume that was
because nothing was found worthy we
usually have 15 people voting entries
often win by small margins but sometimes
seven people can feel very strongly
about an entry and the 8th boat just is
not there don't take that as a sign of
our failing or anyone elses take it as a
sign of how strongly people feel about
what they are voting on and their
commitment to be true to their
judgements and our standards without
fear or favor so for all these reasons
and more i want to say what a privilege
it has been to serve on this board it's
a lot of work but i wish i could have
nine more years well maybe three
thank you very much
thank you and now I want to introduce my
co chair greg moore and sig to do the
real business of the day and pass out
the awards thanks thanks
you